.
IT'S TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
>> Laura: MAYOR, THANK YOU.
WE WISH YOU GOOD LUCK.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
STORY, NOW THE STORY RAGING, ONE
WEEK AGO A MAN NAMED ALEXIS
SEVERIN OF SHAKOPEE, MINNESOTA,
WAS ARRESTED AFTER BEHEADING A
WOMAN IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
TO PAINT THIS CRIME THAT BARELY
MADE NATIONAL NEWS, THE MOTIVE,
WHO WAS THIS MAN?
DID YOU HAVE ANY CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND?
WAS HE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN?
NOT ALL OF THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
OBSCURED, NOT WORTHY OF
EXAMINATION UNTIL ONE MINNESOTA
ATTORNEY AND BLOGGER STARTED
DIGGING.
NOW SCOTT JOHNSON IS A POPULAR
POWER LINE BLOG, JOINING ME NOW,
TELL US WHAT YOU LEARNED AND WHY
OTHERS SEEMED DISINTERESTED IN
THIS SHOCKING AND GRISLY SCHOOL
STORY?
>> LAURA, IT'S REALLY A
HEARTBREAKING STORY AS YOU
SUGGEST, AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON IT FOR THE PAST WEEK, THIS
MAKING AN INITIAL APPEARANCE ON
THE MURDER CHARGE THIS PAST
FRIDAY, AND IN THE COURSE OF
THAT HEARING IN THE INITIAL
APPEARANCE, HE SAID HE WANTED TO
BE DEPORTED TO HIS COUNTRY, THAT
GOT MY ATTENTION.
THE MAN THAT THIS -- THE FACT
THAT THIS BEHEADING HAPPEN IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT IN THE
TWIN CITIES SUBURB OF SHAKOPEE,
MINNESOTA, ON A RESIDENTIAL
STREET GOT MY ATTENTION.
AND AT THE TIME HE BEHEADED HIS
GIRLFRIEND, AMERICO FARRAR, A AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CITIZEN OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO CHANGED
HER NAME TO AMERICA WHEN SHE
BECAME A CITIZEN, SHE WAS -- HE
WAS ON HIS WAY TO COURT OF THREE
FELONIES, INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY
VIOLENT THAT ALSO INFUSED --
INCLUDED THE USE OF A MACHETE
THAT HE USED ON HIS WAY TO COURT
A WEEK AGO WEDNESDAY.
SO BOTH THINGS TAKEN TOGETHER
ARE JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
HAVE WE EVER HAD A PUBLIC
BEHEADING IN BROAD DAYLIGHT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Laura: AND HIS IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS WHAT?
HOW DID HE GET INTO THE COUNTRY?
>> HE CAME, HE IS A CUBAN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
HE ENTERED THROUGH EL PASO IN
2007, AND BY 2012 THERE WERE TWO
DEPORTATION ORDERS THAT HE HAD
RACKED UP.
AND I.C.E. WAS NOT ABLE TO
DEPORT HIM BECAUSE CUBA WOULD
NOT TAKE HIM BACK.
SO WE THEN HAVE BEEN STUCK WITH
HIM.
AND HE HAS BEEN A ONE-MAN CRIME
WAVE BEATING UP WOMEN AND
COMMITTING CRIMES FOR THE PAST
TEN YEARS.
>> Laura: WE CAN LOOK FORWARD
TO MORE GRISLY CRIMES GIVEN WHAT
HAS HAPPENED AT THE BORDER OVER